thank you Mr Speaker in the 13 years of
the last Labor government there were no
National NHS strikes if the Prime
Minister had negotiated with the nurses
Before Christmas they wouldn't be on
strike
it negotiated with the ambulance workers
they wouldn't be on strike either
so why is he choosing to prolong the
misery rather than end these strikes
Minister Mr Speaker we've always been
clear that we want to have constructive
dialogue with the unions that is that
his own that also why when it comes to
the issue of pay we have accepted in
full the independent recommendations of
the pay-per-view bodies then now The
Honorable gentleman simply doesn't have
a policy when it comes to this question
if you
've talked he talks about wanting to end
the stripes the question for him is
simple then why does he not support our
minimum safety legislation
we all know why we all know why Mr
Speaker it's because he's on the side of
his Union paymasters not patients
Mr Speaker when I clap nurses I meant it
his response
his response to the greatest crisis in
the history of the NHS is to threaten to
sack our nurses
this transport secretary says it's not
the solution his education secretary
hopes it won't apply in schools his own
assessments say it could increase the
number of Stripes the simple truth is
you can't legislate your way out of 13
years of failure
between 2010 and 2019 before anyone had
heard of covid prime minister the number
of people stuck on the NHS waiting list
double
foreign
s always wait longer under the Tories
the what
the new year I want to start off with
the refresh chamber but certainly not by
Interruption prime minister
well Mr Speaker he talks about the
minimum safety legislation let's just
talk about it a little bit further
because this is a simple proposition
that no one no one denies the Union's
freedom to strike but it is also
important to balance that with people's
right to have access to life-saving
health care at the same time Mr Speaker
this this shouldn't be controversial
this shouldn't be controversial the
international labor organization
supports minimum service levels
we we have that they're present in
France in Italy in Spain normally he's
in favor of more European alignment Mr
Speaker why not now
Mr Speaker they've gone from clapping
their doses to sacking the nurses it's
that simple
and to add insult to injury they're the
cause of the crisis his government
commissioned a report on waiting times
he knows this his own report says this
is not a covered problem it's 10 years
of managed decline as a result 7.2
million people are now waiting for
treatment
he says he wants to be held to account
over that
so let's be very clear is his promise
merely to get those numbers back to
where they were before covid that's 4.6
million or back to where labor had them
in 2010 almost half of that which is it
Mr Speaker again let's just start with
the facts The Honorable gentleman seems
to completely ignore the fact that not
just in England but in Scotland and in
Wales and in many other European
countries kovid has had an extraordinary
impact on Health Services now now we we
have a very clear plan to bring the
waiting list down and it's one that the
NHS supports but I tell you I tell you
what the NHS doesn't need what they
don't need is Labor's idea yeah what we
don't need
what they don't need is Labor's only
idea which is for another completely
disruptive top-down unfunded
reorganization buying out every single
GP contract now these aren't my words Mr
Speaker the CEO of the Northfield trust
said it will cost a fortune and it's out
of date just like the labor party
Mr Speaker so he can't tell us how much
he'll reduce waiting list by or when so
much for accountability that he wants as
ever with this prime minister you
scratch the surface and you find there
is nothing there
last month 1.4 million people waited
more than four weeks for a GP
appointment
when labor left government you're
guaranteed an appointment in two days
when does the Prime Minister expect to
get back to that
Mr Speaker when it comes to waiting
lists we've already eliminated two-year
wait list done last year we're on track
we're on track we're on track this
spring to eliminate those waiting 18
months with a clear plan to go further
to eliminate those waiting 52 weeks by
next spring and and we're doing that
with record funding more Community
diagnostic Centers more surgical hubs
and more patient Choice then that's why
Mr Speaker I've made tackling waitlist
one of my five priorities but what what
are his they seem to change every single
week right that first he was against NHS
Outsourcing now he's apparently in favor
of it
is inconsistent unprincipled and in hock
to his youth oh
[Applause]
[Music]
just remind the Prime Minister it's
prime minister's question opposition
questions this
[Applause]
[Music]
I had the Prime Minister say s now
registered with an NHS doctor so he'll
soon enjoy the experience of waiting on
hold every morning at 8am to get a GP
appointment but I can tell him that
those that are waiting now don't want
another round of empty promises or
boasting about what he's done they just
want to know when they'll be able to see
a doctor and this is not just about
routine care
there could be nothing more terrifying
to be told who might have cancer
that's why the last Labor government
brought in a guarantee you'd been seen
by a specialist within two weeks
today 50 000 people are waiting longer
than that 50 000 and everyone in this
house will appreciate the anxiety that
they're feeling so when will cancer
patients once again get the certainty of
Quick Care that they got under labor
[Applause]
Mr Speaker what why why is there a
challenge with cancer times right now I
tell you again again it's just
I just absolutely no understanding of
the situation Mr Speaker what happened
to cancer referrals during covid they
went down by almost two thirds Mr
Speaker that was because of a pandemic
that they went down and by the way if we
had stayed and listened to him we'd
still be in lockdown and there'd be a
bit more waiting
right now there are record levels of
cancer treatment as we catch up with
those missed things but he talks about
what's terrifying Mr Speaker what's
terrifying is right now what's
terrifying is that right now people not
knowing whether when they call 999 they
will get the treatment that they need
now Mr Speaker
not in Australia in Australia and Canada
and the US they banned strikes on Blue
Light Services we're not doing that all
we're saying is that then these
Emergency Services patients should be
able to rely on a basic level of
life-saving care why is he against that
Mr Speaker
there's not a minimum level of service
any day because they've broken the NHS
he's not promising that people would get
to see a doctorate a few days like they
did under labor he's not promising that
cancer patients would get urgent
treatment as they did under labor he's
not even promising an NHS that puts
Patients First like it did under labor
no he's promising that that one day
although we can't say when their record
high waiting lists will stop growing
I see
after 13 years in government what does
it say but the best they can offer is
that at some point they might stop
making things worse
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker when it comes to the NHS it's
Crystal Clear the conservatives on the
side of patience labor on the side of
their Union paymasters